welcome back to GameSpot David demo
stayed here at e3 2017 slightly more
populated stage that we own so you are
joining David myself we have Daniel from
Nintendo treehouse we have Krista Joey
Jake an off-screen we have Sara here to
play splatoon
two guys what mode we could be playing
so yeah so this is a new mode added of
the game away from the main mode the
four on for turf more people familiar
with this is called salmon run this is a
cooperative game of up to two to four
players and we're gonna be showing it
off here with these guys taking it on
choosing different weapons
splatoon to does have that new weapon
called the splat Dooley's which sarah's
picking right now right there showing
off her cool outfit as well
Abbie's a little apron kinda have her
going on there so we're gonna get it
going um start starting from five
percent difficulty to get it going from
there's everyone picks their weaponry
presses a to get ready going the
different um compare depending on which
level you play it on so like we're five
percent now difficulty yes the
difficulty level how difficult does it
get it gets difficult pretty fast the
goal the goal of this mode essentially
is to defeat these boss that keep coming
out at you in different waves by
defeating them they'll turn into golden
eggs and take the golden eggs to your
little home base area which moves around
the map differently and you have a quota
base up the difficulty level so right
now you can see in the upper left corner
this is wave 1 there's three waves yep
I've survived this first way they have
100 seconds to get three golden eggs
okay usually need to feed a boss you get
three golden eggs out of them so had
same familiar play that people are
familiar with you know spittoons like
basically inking everything you want to
cover much the ground with ink as
possible so you can move around and
reload your weapon is you need to and
then it's basics are taking anything
they start appearing out of the water so
here comes these little characters come
out of the ground they're chums
these are not the bosses yet no I'm
gonna see where they're gonna come from
they come from a different angle each
time there are different ones like one
called Maz which is like a shark that
pops out of the ground there's a fly
fish that's a different kind of enemy as
well so gonna see
so we're haven't found any the bosses
yet up there's one I think they found
the drizzler that's that ink is coming
from in the air so you to find out where
she's at he's over here so is the
inghean Agrella now a strategic thing of
okay for you and supply rod yes a point
system yes so there they defeated the
drizzle with that umbrella that iron
umbrella guy now to take the those
golden eggs right to that little basket
right there and they should hit their
quota rates actually pretty well
first try through for a wave one we'll
see how they keep doing you didn't mess
up guys they didn't mess up don't worry
they do well we'll see how they do on
the next typical - laughs so in another
40 seconds they can keep actually
getting more golden eggs they want to
keep going above their quota and keep
loading up more with more more golden
eggs with more points and is this a
limited wave thing or is it just it
going as long with three weeks three
waves this is wave one for the twenty
seconds and look looked okay thank you
top so if you if you get more golden
eggs in this wave do they carry forward
to the next video carry over Ben get
more points so this is a stinger right
there these took out nice hopefully they
can see if they can get some of these
golden eggs up to the top before the
timer runs out hoping to take one egg at
a time when I get time per player right
so but if you leave the eggs in the
ground though too sometimes they'll
actually snatch them up and run away you
have to be careful that got my egg and
guys they got four eggs in there I want
to clear two now but all reset back to
the story back to a starting point as
they all start and now a new wave
endings will come I think the core will
go up to four now they have to try to
get four which means it's at least eat
defeat two of the bosses yeah the water
rises it changes the stage constantly
now they're playing over a local network
right now they're playing over local
wires essentially at the moment but it
normally to play online you can always
play it anytime you want over up there's
laws you play over the overall local
network anytime you want if you want to
play online it's gonna be like a splat
like splatfest it's a timed event a
time-based event so it'll be good to
find out from those times will be will
announce them and then you can jump it
in boy this is co-op how does it work if
if one of these things get like what
happens if they if they okay if someone
gets busy splat it out from the enemy
they turn into a life preserver I think
it float around and then your teammates
can shoot ink on them to bring them back
right there kind of builds from there as
well no one's gone down yeah you're all
good I know the other actually pretty
good why shut up the difficulty on yeah
like to a hundred percent Oh we'll jump
it based on their planting like gold
leaf we'll try 50 or 60 see how they
when they get through that so they're
already I'm waved to so we'll see a few
more minutes for this and see what they
can discover and find we need one more
eggs meter quota are you doing the find
you gotta find a boss then
no boss sir I'm gonna go and is there
like an alert or an indication of where
the boss might be no you're gonna find
them and then they get stuck up there it
is oh wow okay I gotta talk teammates
have to talk to each other
you can hear them talking next to us
right now Joey Krista and Jake and Sarah
off sup officer off-screen guys they
have 30 seconds to get one of those
golden eggs in there Adam as a game over
if they don't mean if they don't yeah
they don't get the quarter they they
fail okay they have to start over we
beat the quarter now we before six eggs
they got six we knew as high as you want
with as you want to so yeah that's the
fun part of this one day I'll just
working together in that communication
you have any advantage to beating the
the Chloe there's more points you get
you get scored at the very end a little
thing to see how you guys use score
white you also do have your specials so
you do but you'd only use it twice for
the entire wave okay
that's steelhead over there that's
another one of them he's hard like he
basically has a little grenade inflate
on his head you have to destroy it
before he shoots off that grenade off
his head and the water rising I suppose
that's a way to keep the map dynamic and
the matching raise some difficulty to
bottleneck third is really high waters
really high ball because English you
remember can't swim right they die when
they fall in why so and the home base
can also move sometimes as well so now
there's less space move around it may
start from them there's a scrapper so if
you go behind so you shoot from the
front or you can sneak behind him and
actually find his weaker point from
behind which may secure so it's also
working in like sometimes you got on
when we get to the neck we get the next
difficulty which we'll do in just about
60 seconds we had a chance to see what
it's like when you have two more
communicate sometimes one person should
be covering the ground
well one person's we're only taking up
the the boss characters hitei makes a
challenge for everybody so so far so
good they only have three eggs in there
so far I sneaked two more eggs how many
maps are you looking to so far only
showing one it's the only map we've
shown so far so I'll stay tuned this is
a WoW so the front of him is invincible
big wait go back there's actually a
little driver in the back of it Adam up
third round but I should have seen
oxygen that life preserver
you made seen the shooter and boom hey
one more egg guys I got you here we go
yeah back here so they're all working on
her you're actually really good really
it's a good cohesive team so about 20
seconds we'll get a chance to see the
next level difficulty so that'll be fun
to see how well they do with that hey
yeah that's what I'm kind of how high do
you want to make your difficulty go up
to oh no I don't have a turn there here
I do good it the Dave does however you
want put it up Gabe let's say like I
reckon I could handle six sixty percent
yeah okay like how well they're doing
already a little having me up the
difficulty to like the water level cause
you see changes will start adding fog
into the game you have Eagle Park at
night I succeded this voice now they'll
actually jump back to their home base
which is a little boat a little tugboat
off to the side and then they basically
got all those same those golden eggs GG
guys yeah we get the reports that you
peeed reporter every time good job good
job team
hey cheering themselves Luigi Mario
Yoshi impeached by name for this one
that's not really them and now we're
gonna jump the difficulty up to see how
they did yeah let's go for sixty oh boy
I think you feeling me my pinkies feels
confident guys confidence come on
I believe in you I believe in you okay
and you notice how they cheat it even
changes another overachievers good job
overachiever I like to change that when
you old achieve so all I'm gonna hit say
to get in there waiting for Yoshi yep
now we're all in and now we'll see how
they do in this in this next mode oh man
ever this is a this is just an all dust
this is a new mode to the game and there
is still that classic mode the forearm
for online multiplayer game that
splatoon is known for basically like
turf war carping everything in ink or
tower control or splat zones all those
kind of modes are still available in the
game with new maps and new weapons as
well a new gear and just got random
color yes to get a random coast now
they're all playing with pink ink and
we'll see how they this time at level 60
see it's starting to turn a little
darker now oh yeah oh you gotta get a
eggs then you get eight eggs in 100
seconds in wave one I'm sorry
hey ed that's that need an Egypt beach
boss using three eggs okay so that means
they get a defeat at least three
different bosses and not lose any of the
Ellen can lose only one
good thing this is not high tide so yeah
it's true this a little bit so who's
playing as to Serie Sara's playing as as
Mario yes and then I'm not sure what you
guys are playing Kristen we got Jake
playing as peach Joey as Yoshi and
Krishna playing as Luigi nice so tell
with these guys to you so far so far so
good
there's one of that's so what other
variables are there when you increase
the difficulty like it's more enemy or
from everywhere is it it is a better
strategy to sort of avoid the grunts and
just go straight for the boss or other
grunts gonna really make your life the
grunts will make your life a living in
that problem yeah oh yeah I said some of
the fuel sorry can you get over whelmed
lads I'll start bringing up a lot on the
same like you've know so far it's been
40 only if they've used half the time
they have no golden eggs guys
yep get that and I'll to recover you a
little bit going on a timer or they is
it is there is demo search need to help
go hope out in the action over there
there's the action going on over here
so these are like explosive crates here
yeah they can go thank is that just
another way for them to spawn rather
than get water
ah if you notice now they've been trying
great as you guys me only got I have no
golden eggs yet you doing guys they're
about to fail in 16 seconds I think I
can still get eight in 10 seconds yeah
an optimist oh one day again there's one
no one died though which is impressive
yeah oh the enemy ankles it slows him
down huh
yeah he got o negs okay maybe not
sixteen pump its back down they scored
well but yes right we gonna try with 40
see ya see if that brings more enemies
up there I know just right the right
sweet spot to see but yeah generator
from their success rate is they're kind
of like the weapons you take on is there
an advantage of having different ones
depending on the map with the enemy or
the enemy so yes I do meet everyone's
gonna come with their own strategy what
their weapon preferences are what they
like to use um I'm a big fan of the
splattershot flash our jr. um I know
Sarah likes the splat really so does
krysta right now
it's pulling me with the splat do we see
that while you're shooting if you jump
you kind of do a roll so you can dodge
I'm really cool I'm late I just kind of
spring out what you want to do what
works best for your team like that's
people
better with different weapons that's
right another play style just kind of
figure out what works best for each team
dynamic and how you want to play through
that this is not doc this time yeah not
dark this time so we'll see where it
goes from there so far so good
when it's misty and dark that's me yes
the fog kicks in that's when you're in
trouble now we'll see how they do this
time so as again they're the traffic
they're trying to cover as much as they
can with ink now so they can move around
more easily reload more easier as well
because as those as the enemies are
coming up they do start changing the
color of the ink ah
which makes slows down your movement you
can't refill your own your own own
weapons as well then eight seven eggs
this time oh there's more right behind
him someone got splatted showing up and
there's there's Moz again no he's back
okay going down pretty soon everything
lost somebody somebody went down that
big fish nice ma they got my Co take
those eggs back to the homies I got
three so far they need to get seven
we're doing okay right now hey I think
you got this guy's
yeah thanks these are boys mom's coming
back mom you sure this cook all people
and some people have really died pretty
quickly on 10% so it's actually good to
these guys doing so well as a team
anyone beyond 100 yet I have never I
tried it and I like in 30 seconds Wow uh
what I've heard I think Christa's of the
dev teams actually done home for sure
Wow game hope they can any one cat so
far two guys are down up they'll all
back up okay everybody up we got an egg
here we're out yeah Wow one person down
Sarah's down Sarah uh got a lot of eggs
in here Sarah I got you'll head hey hey
now there's a lot happening on the
screen
Flattr here but I'm carrying in is that
like two bosses on the screen ready yes
look at me please
something's four or five you like laughs
hit the quote no they hit the quote at
the scene more intense than the high
difficulty yes because they were Yeti
really everywhere you live we're gonna
get one of us fight the hoe yeah he's
ready dug it up they say their kid was
ready first wave oh that was close you
got this but you got a moment of
right between yeah the ten seconds yeah
ten seconds to racing we clear up the
screen get ready get that ink they they
lost covered back up and they rockin
rollin
so we'll see either you this time does
the egg basket change location is it
it's been seen the same way some say
camera beautiful location like there's a
little beachhead can go over there which
actually is one of my least favorite
spots for it to appear because then it
gets hard to get out there oh don't the
enemy of the buyer here nope there's Maz
all right little warning oh hi drizzles
coming out yep the umbrella Panama
everyone still alive you guys are good
Oh somebody back to Syria yeah oh yeah a
little help sign up and we regs yep but
there's eggs next to me so someone
should there you go thanks Mario oh no
no way down let's plot it again two
people down okay I'm Ivan Chad Cassidy
each peach sells out and you can with a
scooping you kidding while you're in the
life preserver mode too so you can
attach it there any mates and you leave
the golden egg up steep he just took him
he's running away with it yeah you got
it back nice see try just do what they
do
now there's tool steel heads on the slab
I'm halfway there
really crazy didn't know whatever I'm
skilled yes I think so I say look what's
that up no big bar that a grenade you
can't defeat the steel head you have to
wait till that you have to destroy it
Walt's on his head okay [ __ ] you down
malas coming out oh oh 20 seconds when I
say gonna get two more golden eggs tense
duh oh the valley in last and dinner can
they get golden egg oh my gosh getting
swarmed I just feel coming
just covered it and they all died oh
very close yeah one way for yes let's
save and run right there good yeah guys
really like fast and fronting yes I like
the difference between there's so much
more than exactly I'm worried about
going on that screen what size 60% I'll
be fine yeah and you're gonna find no it
gets really intense you get higher in
those difficulties yeah sure
well guys thank you so much for coming
and playing the game she liked me first
attentive us not very not for long yeah
for sure
I'm for more dip make sure you don't go
anywhere we're gonna have total war
Warhammer to right up next